food wine it was
the city for I shall fight
hi Eddie so Hallie Lambie
I'm Ali
yeah no I don't wanna have that car
screaming debate like what weighs it
it's just what one understand is
basically they were saying that they
said Jesus goes toilet so is that what
they were saying that's some of them
yeah okay yeah I thought it how can
Jesus eat drink sleep but they don't
understand we believe that the invisible
God became visible in the Lord Jesus
Christ we believe that Jesus is take on
flesh is fully God and fully human he's
the only person who's to nature one of
his nature is humanity and as the nature
is his divinity okay that's what the
Bible said and that's what I believe
okay that's that's really fair and maybe
there will be aggressive I don't like to
be aggressive well when you say he's
fully human and fully fully God I
respect that
so if it is human nature and he has a
divine nature when when they asked him
about the hour why did he say only the
Father Knows right like because if he
has both of them inside him if he's
together one do they how does it work
because either he's all-powerful or he's
not powerful either he knows it all he
doesn't know it all either he's one or
the other which one does he work why
which one did he say today I'm going to
be like this or I'm gonna be latter
because they both country together so
that's what we're coming from like how
does it work to answer that question I
have to tell you a story in order to
back up the background for example do
you have an earthly father yeah you have
a father I have a father how a positive
that's your father greater than you not
really no why would you be greater than
me I mean in what in what context and
for example in when I say that your
father greater than you I don't mean
that you are 75 percent human and 25
personal but always your father or your
grandfather is greater than you great
about it respectfully yes well I mean in
every way well no every way because the
things in my mind forever
born of your father isn't it yeah but my
father can be a bad person I can be a
good person so I can be greater than him
in a bow that I'm talking about when
Jesus Christ said I do not now no one
knows the hour
even the Angels even the Sun only the
father why did he say that okay so he
was basically sitting as far as I know I
don't know because I'm not
and I don't know the answer of all your
question but I try to make the best and
I can and trying to answer you as much
as I can I respect you honestly I
respect I Jesus said no one now's our
accepted it know even the angel the
ovens the Sun but God's a father why did
he say that because Jesus Christ in his
humanity for example he was not
omniscient he was only in Holy Land I
freedom in Israel in Palestine
whatever was it in that time so Jesus
Christ he never came to thirty okay he
never came to UK or America whatever
ages he was always in the because it was
not omniscient at that time so when he
said no one now's the time even the Sun
in his humanity because he proves that
he is fully God and fully human in his
humanity he didn't know the our star to
the Father that's why in the garden of
gamma Sheen before he he was crucified
he said therefore father
it is possible take away this cup from
me but not my will but your will be done
and then he said in the John he said now
therefore father glorify your son with
the glory I had in the beginning with
you was that mean so Jesus Christ he's
sharing the same nature a different
position when he came to earth he was
having different position at the same
nature with God Yahweh but the thing is
what the things that you are seeing it's
all based in the Bible yeah okay now
what I want to do is I can argue with
you all day long and I can say the Bible
says is that says that it says that but
I want to cut it from the roots I don't
want to go to the branches do you
believe the Bible is the Word of God
okay can the Word of God have any errors
or contradictions in it Bible is eternal
we don't believe we don't believe that
that Bible has been sent down from
heaven we don't believe that the Bible
we believe that the Bible has been
changed we know where's the change so
you okay okay hold on a second hold on a
second now where's the change so so you
said that you know the Bible has been
changed and without words a change okay
I respect you for your honesty I also
just respect that I know because you're
honest I respect that the Bible is
complete okay but hold on a second did
you say so who's your name Christopher
you said we know that the Bible has been
changed because we found out
where the change okay yeah how can it be
the Word of God if you found that it's
been changed you know this word sorry
this word has been added to the Bible by
who by I don't know by who could be by
the church could be by the Vatican okay
that you okay I'm an expert on you okay
okay that's why I'm sorry I can't now
can I just make this I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry yeah you said that you realize
that the Bible has been changed maybe
from the church maybe from whoever
that's why the Koran says woe to those
who change the scriptures with their own
hand and says from Allah so now you have
acknowledged and said like yes it has
been changed maybe from the church how
do you still believe that is the Word of
God if you know why I believe because
when you for example when you read from
Genesis to Revelation yes even at the
moment I'm reading the King James
Version which I also use I you know II
think inconvenient no no is what I
believe the Holy Spirit revealed to me
is that the King James Version is the
only reliable okay okay the Holy Spirit
told you that's a reliable one yeah but
there's other Christians that will read
the New International Version and they
say the Holy Spirit told me that this is
the right one it's okay so but so sorry
so which Holy Spirit is a right one for
me Christopher Christopher hear me up
which Holy Spirit is the correct one cuz
you see he told me this book is right
I'm not telling you another one is
saying took the Holy Spirit talk to me
for example for example you are seeing a
crime before the accident car accident
wrongful act the testimony other
witnesses so you're gonna go in a
different angle my friend yes from that
side from data in front of it when
you're asking about the same accident
like a same car garage you have about
four or five people they all give you a
different you're right Chris Babb OPSEC
accident you're right beside me that all
of them are wrong no no no you're right
but Christopher
if we saw an accident happening a man
got hit by a car yeah we all sorry our
story might change but one thing that we
would agree on is a car hit a man yes I
might say the car was green I'll say no
I saw a bit yellow but the main thing
that the car hit a man is there that's
it but when it agree on that yeah but
you're telling me the book the Bible is
a word of God and you said it's been
changed and these tunics it is the Word
of God how I'm asking you as a brother
like I try to answer you
we believe that this vs. has been added
to the Bible we know I told you already
I don't know could be the church could
be Vatican could be Pope I don't know
how do they change God's words and I
don't know it's been said ok but if I
mistake I don't know but we now we're
the change but I why because we have
about 60 person of the manuscript in a
British Museum
you
you
you
here which is give us the authentic the
authentic okay of the Bible for example
we know where the change so Johnson yeah
than 750 that doesn't change my faith in
the Lord Jesus Christ why because the
casually the Protestant the Baptist the
Jehovah Witness know so Joe of witness
but this major denomination like
Protestant Cassidy in a Baptist we all
have one thing in common
one principle Jesus Christ born of the
Virgin he was within 33 years old
listen is what we believe that is what
Muslim we believe that Jesus Christ
afire we don't believe don't believe
that he buried and he rose again on the
third day so that's a principle I live
in by that principle I don't have a
problem when when when I don't know who
was it somewhere who was it was
commanded to go to kill all the amorite
I don't have a Mel Amalekites America
okay I don't know America's in
everything is samuel chapter version
commanded to do what Samuel did i'm not
commanded to do what Moses did I am
commanded to do what Jesus did jesus
said love your enemy and bless those who
persecute you okay but you need to
understand I respect everything that you
said but I'm saying let's not go to the
branches let's cut it from the root the
you said all these stories that you have
told me about Jesus's crucifixion all
the things are in the Bible yes yeah has
the Bible being changed yes I told you
already
okay krystal krystal hear me up change
my respect I'm not going to force you I
Mavericks a change but hear me out
you're telling me everything that I've
told you about Jesus's resurrection and
the doctrine of Christianity is in the
Bible I'm not okay good
that's fine is the Bible reliable you
say no it's being changed I didn't say
no it's not reliable it's been changed
okay you know what okay you don't say
okay I haven't I'm sorry can I can I
make okay why I was seeing it if
something can you rely on me from a
dodgy man no that's different
no no I'm telling you I'm you know me
Ali Ali Zaffis I've wrote people yeah i
pickpocket I don't trust you why I don't
trust you wow you're a dirty person
hold on a second hold on a sec okay I
told you we know what
okay Christo can I make my cannot come
at my point please please you wouldn't
trust me because I'm a dodgy guy but you
trust the Word of God which is been sent
down but is being changed
tell me how how does that work why
because I already told you well you know
why do you trust me I thought why don't
you trust me
can I ask you a question about your
brother do you believe that the Quran is
eternal would you mean by eternal like
is it going to be with us for eternity
if you know it mean it's a plane was in
heaven before God created to have
another earth yes yes yes that's right
as far as I know yes is the Orion is in
heaven
yes the Quran down yes do you know at
least two chapter of the Holy Quran yes
has been eaten by the same ship okay the
chapter of breastfeeding
okay the top of the stoning of women do
you have evidence for Lazarus Ayesha
Ayesha Sahil Muslims ahead bhai we were
preoccupied by the death of the Prophet
Mohammed we had a tame goat yes no Shiv
is that we have attained God as a tame
God came and he ate the two chapters
you
from two chapters was eaten by the God
at least two chapters are okay okay okay
okay Christopher for the sake of the
argument let's see I agree I said you
know what they were eating when the
Quran came down was it written down or
memorized by the people was memorizes
memorized by the people edition mm all
right okay okay okay now okay
it was memorized method by the people
yes yeah okay I want to give you an
example please understand if all of us
know the timetable by heart you know
timetable 1 x times 2 times 2 yeah we
all know the timetable my heart yes if
he comes and says I wrote down five
times five not for example he comes and
says 5 times 5 is 60 is 5 times 5 60
know what guys guys guys I wanted to
cooperate with me yet what is 5 times 5
25 if he comes and says is 60 what do we
do we correct him when we are praying in
the Masjid and the Imam makes a mistake
what happens in the back we correct him
now no nobody's coming the answers
coming be ready for here now if it's
been memorized by people let's suppose
that the goat ate 2 chapters do we have
thousands of companies that know the
Quran by heart
yeah ok so even if that verse was eaten
for example wouldn't they say ok it's ok
we'll just write it on a new copy look
she's not booking she's talking about
two verses that way to my devote
laughing yeah that's really yeah
I'm telling you you'll tell me these
verses were gone I'm telling you there
was thousands of companions that knew it
by heart how does it go where you turn
what about the man who said I myself for
God - chapter of the Quran he memorized
ok and Muhammad ok ok Muhammad said this
man I can't even be simple is a very
difficult name it's all scoured I can't
remember two minutes but he says this
man if you want to hear the recitation
from any man come to this man because he
is the best of the recitation and he
himself if you go to the third in the
Sahel Bukhari he himself said I have
forgotten to chapter of the Quran okay
who's there other computer what was it
only one that knew the Quran by heart he
says so he was the oh no no no the
Prophet recommended him okay but was he
the only one that knew the Quran by
heart but the other one the only one a
mercy Ali that's how you gonna how you
gonna no no no no Christmas Ron
Christopher he was what he was
recommended by Mohammed K he said if you
want to hear the recitation yes
this is the best man in mark or Medina I
don't know
he's the best man come to him okay and
he will give you the reciting no problem
a master who is here only one that knew
the Quran yes according to the according
to Mohammed was e the only amount of
recitation okay based on recitation
you're talking about preservation was he
the only one that knew the Quran well
many people knew thank you the other day
okay yeah sure that's not me saying the
time stable I forgot 12 times 12 so we
lost it no you see I know how smart
chick my friend that's my party - my
memorize it's also show that you just
told me when the imam make a mistake you
couldn't work correcting yes so your
scholar are not perfect they don't know
every similar piranhor
they make a mistake so is this money get
corrected Ali at least this man he
forgot to chapter of the Quran and
nobody knew okay that's what the hobby
said nobody knew this - job that trust
me I will give you the website what do
you serve the Quran you know where if
that's the case if that's the case why
do we have millions of people that know
the Quran from China to Russia to
everybody they agree on it
yes recitation yeah he said he said I
have forgotten two chapters of Quran no
I have there's many people that knew it
but they didn't know what's the evidence
the evidence is he says so
the Haditha gold it go to Google no
sorry go to youtube and on YouTube right
exaggeration now listen listen people
you want to sort and use the video use
the videos funny because the al Muslim
you go to even a shark you've got even
and got also use all I have done this
YouTube video who did a video well this
is Adama because the resources you did
that YouTube videos a Muslim Sam is
Nabil crochet with a Muslim that it was
a
emotional testable crazy
you
yes I'm talking about this subject they
have no audio he wasn't you are these -
who are these that bill crazy and David
would you are them they're Christian how
do you out in a second listen you're
giving me reference appreciate that more
Muslim Christopher no he's not he was an
enemity I mean is no Muslim
first of all Muslim apologists of Armond
Qureshi for Honda is a former um let me
see if I get this right Ahmadiyya
Ahmadiyya
you
so let's start out I actually used to
believe the same things that piranha
used to believe before he became an
orthodox Sunni Muslim then almost a bit
closer to Christianity than Islam of
course we finish so while we have
understood is I thank you very much for
your time that that debate the sorry
that the Bible like you said has been
changed we now where the change yes we
are that's all I need to know that's all
I need to know the truth and it's all
reliable now you still argue that the
cannot be changed
van Gogh we believes are not be changes
you